this is gonna be a pretty heavy loaded
workshop and hopefully we will
make it in time uh but well we will be
starting with um the intro uh basically
what this workshop is and what it isn't
and then we will start with the project
setup
we will get our environments up and
running so that everyone are
on the same page and and can start
working
uh after that we will start with uh the
viewer router
how can we use it to to basically
not be well to create the navigation of
our page
uh then we will see how to fetch data
and handling loading states for our
application
um after that we'll be seeing bx
how to start and share data between
components
uh after that first half we will be
seeing a form validation and basically
try to do a form
and validate it and the view way we
should be doing it
and finally uh we're gonna
just really quick see view test utils
to create a test for a component at the
end
we will have a q a session like as i
mentioned before
and if there's something we didn't cover
uh you can basically ask anything around
view and well in its ecosystem
all right so well now that uh
i mentioned we we were gonna explain
what this workshop
is but first what with this workshop
isn't
this is not an intro to view so probably
if you don't
you don't know view yes um you you won't
enjoy it as if you knew it because i
won't be explaining
uh basic topics right i'll try to go to
uh to more advanced topics like if uh
assuming you know yes already and have
used it before
uh this is also not an html css or
javascript course
um so i'm not gonna be explaining uh
well things like uh the styles of the
components we
we're going to be using most of them are
already done and set up so they i
i won't explain that on like too deep
js has a little asterisk because
we will learn some js tips because vue
works with
javascript right so yeah we will learn
js but not
necessarily is ijs course and
this is not another to-do app so if you
already done those for every
language that there exists don't worry
this is not going to be that
and also this is not a design system
workshop so if you this is not a
workshop to learn how to create
design systems and probably the
components we're going to be using are
not uh
made for a design system uh but
what this workshop is is a worship to
learn new year's
best practices if you already know ugs
this is gonna step up your game
and help you uh have clean code
uh also uh this is to learn how to use
all of you tools um for well all of the
ecosystem of view
which is for routing for state
management and debugging
and testing i i forgot to add that at
the end
um it's for people that are tired to do
making to do apps because this is like a
more real
app and you're gonna see that in in in a
few minutes
um okay so the idea is
that you are in in the middle of this in
the left is people that
have just read about you and probably
follow a tutorial
you should be more in the middle
uh you should have used view in the past
and probably done a pet project
and after this course you'll be
more on the right where you'll know
viewing its ecosystem and also
you'll be use it to create a client
solution all right
so probably some of you might be asking
why should you
trust that i know bgs and
well the thing is that i'm a close
friend of avenue
which is the creator of you and
that's why he just tells me all of his
secrets and
no just kidding uh the real facts
uh we've been working with you for more
than three years
uh also uh i've written blog posts about
making
uh some components with vs you can go to
this
link by the way we're going to be
sharing that the presentation most
likely so that
if you don't follow so that you don't
need to write all of the links i
am clicking and well you can find them
on on dev too
this this posts also
i've deployed over 20 sites and apps
well not
not just me but me and my team and
including one of these sites is a
site with nearly 2 million visitors in a
month and
that's basically a top 10 new site in
the united states and
if you
[Music]
meet just like
okay so
get ready and let's start with the
project setup
uh you you should have received an email
or
at least some uh some way you you should
have known that you need to to have node
installed and npm
if you go to your terminal and try node
v you should be seeing a
version of node let's try it here
and it's okay if it's not the same
version but
as long as the version shows that's fine
and well as long as it's
not super low like probably above
six is okay um but you'll find out if
your version is okay when we
install the dependencies also something
important is the view
of tools and this is really useful when
developing with view
so if you have it you can open
your well you can click here inspect it
will show your browser console and you
should
see uh a view that when we are running
the project
uh probably right now you won't see it
but you should see it uh
in in your extensions probably sorry
i need to track this oh yeah there it is
sorry i have too many extensions
and also is recommended but not
necessary
bs code and these plugins bigger and
prettier because
they will help a lot to scaffold
code and also to make it pretty and the
view cli
it's also not necessary we won't be
using it but
the project i'm gonna be sharing with
you
what's done with bcli so just if you
want to recreate that
that's a very very useful tool
cool um also uh
well before we start if you're if i'm
going too fast or
or something please tell in the chat too
um so let's start cloning i'm sorry
planning the repo
i wasn't going to copy uh this url i'm
pasting on
the chat so that you can clone this so
basically you
if you go to a folder in your terminal
and run this command you should be able
to to clone the project right
i have already cloned it so
i can show you real quick how it should
look
and it's basically a project with all of
these
folders and files so i'll wait
a little bit um for you to to download
that
and well after doing that we are going
to be
needing to to run npm install or mpmci
i'll start doing that although i
already have it installed
npm hi i'm sorry
so yeah it should install all of the
dependencies
and when you're done with that uh we're
gonna be
running the server with npm run surf
so i'm just gonna wait a little bit for
for this to happen you can
also start asking questions if you're
already done if you
have everything running
okay so going to run npm brown surf
just so that you know you can see what
the
the site should look like
okay so if you have everything running
basically
your site should look like this and i'll
put the instructions here so that
you can keep seeing them
all right remember to put yes in
in the zoom controls you have probably
on your right side
we we just have seven people we need
more
okay uh yeah there there are some people
that probably will have problems with
their
setup so uh yeah
you we we can as i mentioned we will be
uploading this to
youtube so yeah you can follow up on
this and probably if you
have time later and you fixed
your your setup you can also re-run it
with your
with your pc
but also charlie and nothing can help
you
to troubleshoot whatever is happening
remember to use qq between brackets
uh so first uh i'm gonna show you that
the project real quick that's why i
also opened this package.json
as i mentioned this is a vcli project
you can run
you create and the name of your app and
it will ask you a bunch of questions of
what you want for
uh for the project right for starters
um well it installed you of course
and also i i asked to to install the
view router
ux which we're gonna be learning
and for for this site i use tailwind
which is a css library that basically i
used to
quickly do the the site but this is not
going to be the focus
of the course just so that you know what
i'm using here
oh another important thing i installed
was axios
for fetching data we're going to be
using that in in the third or four or
four
chapter of of this workshop and
finally uh the view test details and
guests
are are also installed so that we can
test the the components with with yest
and i'm gonna do a really quick overview
of the project
and the folders um basically you'll find
out well
this is for the distribution files when
we build it
and node modules are what basically npm
install installs
in public we have some assets
like images for our products and our
clients
and also the fab icon and and the main
html where
the view app will mount right the uh if
you already
used view in the past you know that the
html is just a div and view mounts in
that div
right um okay so
after that and we have the source where
where
most of the code we're gonna be using is
gonna be
and we will be working the most and
test is where we are going to make our
test at the end
right in source we have
our main js which is basically just a
view a simple view app
we're importing view we're importing our
component app.view
and we're creating a viewing instance
and mounting it in the
div that i mentioned before all right
the app.view just has these three
components
uh page navigation home view and page
footer
we can see them in in the page
if that's why i told you a bit of tools
are gonna be really useful is if we
open them in this tab
you're gonna see we have the root of the
app then the app top view
then the three components i just
mentioned the footer is
way on the bottom that's why it wasn't
showing but there it is
okay um well apart from those two files
we have
other folders uh in this
assets folder i have the css i'm using
also
and the the image of the printer i have
here by the way it's a 1d printer it
just prints lines
and for components i have already set up
some components that we will be working
on
we just have one filter that will help
us well probably we won't use this but
you'll see that at the end how it looks
uh but basically just turns a number
into
a dollar sign number with uh
well like a money number uh in pages we
have all the pages we're going to be
working
with and the company is this one we have
the hero where the the printer is
showing and
the testimonials of the clients which is
here below what doesn't have anything
we're going to work on that too we have
the also 404
page thank you page etc
and well router and store are
two files that are basically just a
little bit
of code that uh that is basically
empty and we're gonna be adding to
uh because well that's the purpose of
this course to know how to use the
router to store
and and well the rest of the things i
mentioned
so hopefully that was enough time for
you to catch up and have the project
running
and well we will start with with the
view router
um let me just
some things here
okay so well for the router we
we just saw that the page has this
navigation
bar and right now it doesn't do anything
right if you click it
nothing happens and we want to
click it that the url changes and also
the content changes right so
let's do that first uh what we need to
do is on our main js
we need to uh connect the the the router
right i mentioned we have this router
file so
what we're gonna do is import it
and after importing it sorry this should
be
the scan
we just use it well set it up inside
this
view instance right
so i'm gonna wait a little bit for you
to catch up
but this is pretty simple all right it's
just for
you warming up your fingers uh import
the router
and then um just put the the router
inside the
view instance and well
let's check the the the index file of
the router folder
you you'll see that we have set up some
uh scaffolding code um
when you do the app with the vcli this
is done
well all of this except this and this is
something i added because these are the
uh the routes that the client
asked us to do so uh
this is the only thing different and
also the routes are empty i i
put them empty on purpose because if you
see i already add some of them
but i want you to to do them from
scratch
so now let's check if we have everything
connected correctly if we imported that
correctly
we should be able to click on on
anything here
and you'll see that we have the route uh
properly in the data we it is showing us
the pad
and the query and the params which are
empty and the meta
so yeah everything is empty because we
are in the home page
that's cool so we know that's working
but that's not really useful right uh so
let's start by by doing uh
well two routes one for for the homepage
we
we already are in and another one for
for the checkout page which is
the second one so to make a route we
just need to
put an object inside this array and then
put the path which is the url path in
this case
we're going to use the object we have on
and put page.com
the second thing that it needs is a name
a name for the route
in this case oh i'm just going to call
it hum 2.
and oh sorry this should be pages
and after that uh the third parameter
well
uh a tier option you can add to this
object is the component
and well this is needed because that's
the component we want to render
in this page right so i'm gonna write
home here but we don't have the home
component
imported right we're gonna do that here
remember that we had these pages uh
folder here you you'll see we have a
home.view
so we can basically just import home
from
[Music]
pages
right so that's the first route
but well that's not really useful
because that's the same we have
just a home page so i'm gonna just copy
this
paste it and do the same for the
checkout page
i'm gonna wait at the end of this
because i'm probably going a little bit
fast but
you can tell me in the chat if i'm going
too slow or too fast
so i'll do the same check out
and from this i also copy paste it
just change the checkout
component
right so
yeah before i change file i want you to
i want to know if you already got this
it's basically just two
to route pad name component
and that's it right
cool uh well
now i'm uh i cannot test this
yet because well our navigation doesn't
work right
so we need to link to these pages
somehow
we can go to the components inside
of that folder we have the page
navigation
and here we'll find out that we have
three
links but well we just we just have two
two routes the the home page and the
checkout one
so let's link them to those routes
uh what the view router needs to link to
those pages
is not an anchor like i know html works
with
atax but in this case we need to use
something called
a router link
and works basically the same as as an
anchor
but instead of href you put a two
property
so in this case if we want to go to the
home page we put here
the path of that home page right
the same for checkout we do router link
to check out
cool so i'm just gonna wait a little bit
just to see just for you to catch up
sure yeah i can show you the main js
again just in case
uh you didn't put the router in there
i'm just importing it and putting it
inside the view
instance
okay so we already installed the view
router
we added some routes and we
added the router links right so
let's see if that works here we have the
uh the navigation so we click home well
nothing happens
we click checkout it seems that nothing
happened but
look at here at top we have this
checkout uh
url well pat added
so it means that it is working uh this
is changing the url right
but we were missing the content the
content should not be the same
we wanted the checkout page to be
showing here right
so let's get back now to our app.view
and well that is happening because we
have this home view
component hard coded like there's no way
the router know
uh we don't have a way to let the router
know where should it
inject the view right so for that we
will use the router view
and we can get rid of of the home view
because we don't need it anymore
so yeah i just replaced the home view
that was hard coded and now the router
view this will
basically tell the router hey
here you can get the component that was
initialized in the router file right
so now let's get back to the page test
it and we can see it's changing and
also if we look at the
at the tree we can see here we have the
home page but
there's something added at the right
that is telling us that this is the
router view
so when we change the route it changes
for the checkout component
and it's telling you this is a router
view
when it is slash checkout but when the
path uses let's check out
and also if you look at the route it
changes right
we have a path that says slash checkout
we have the name of the route the full
pad all of that changed
right this is before i'm going to check
out in the homepage everything is just a
slash
all right cool so let's see if
everyone's
uh on board on this and i'm just going
to put this screen a little bit so that
you can
catch up and put the router view if you
didn't
i'm not reading anything in the chat
telling me like
i should go faster so i'll assume that
i'm in a good pace
okay so well now if you already have
this running
let's go to an exercise if we go back to
uh to the router dot in i mean the
router index
uh you'll see that we have other pages
right
so let's try to do the the products one
i'm gonna give you uh probably um
five minutes uh for you to add the
products
route and also remember that you need to
go to the page navigation
and change this link and
uh well also the the route should have
the component
and remember our page components are in
this page
folder and we have a products one all
right so uh
probably 4 39
i'll start asking the favorite games
done meanwhile i'll start
uh i mean for for the people that are
are not uh
following them themselves i'll start
doing it
so that um if you don't want to
um to do it by yourself you you can just
follow me
and okay probably
oh okay uh i'm not sure if uh this
question is gonna be answered by
charlie or jonathan uh
so i'm i'm just gonna leave them do that
meanwhile i'll
i'll be adding the next route so
i'm just gonna do it quietly for the
people that are doing it
so
okay so i'm seeing that uh yeah
i'll be answering that is it a good a
good practice to split script
style and template sections in multiple
files
and just import all together uh
well i in my own opinion uh
it's better to have them like in one
place right
the only case i will think of doing that
like splitting them
is just if the component is super big
but in that case i will say that just
extract like certain functionality or
make more components so that that big
component becomes
smaller right
[Music]
um i'm not sure if that answer your
question
okay cool yeah because that's that's the
main advantage of your files the
the single file component file single
file component sorry
uh that you have html css and javascript
and everything
is bound together right like uh
you you can check the the functionality
for all that
remember to use the qq in brackets i'm
i'm just going to
read that question but it's easier for
for the mentors to read them
so the usb feature for listing your view
is called
what do you mean by listing
ah linting okay now uh that's also
in the setup of the project we have
eslint we have some rules here
and yeah it also extends from a view
essential
uh plugin that already has some view
rules like you're gonna see them later
but basically some rules like your
component should not have these and that
or uh and the rest of the rules are
extension of airbnb uh which basically
is like the
trailing and commas and semicolons
and well also i just i added some for
not using console and stuff like that
but
yeah this is also done by the vcli
that's a cool thing
uh and i believe also for pre-tier yeah
i have some
things here set up um is because i want
prettier to put the single quotes
trading commas and parentheses in in the
arrow functions
all right so it's time uh
how many of you were able to do the
exercise
basically what we needed to do was just
add this path
as you can see we're using the pages
that products we have here on top
and the component products was imported
like this
and in our page navigation we just
needed to add the router link
to products and you should be seeing
a page like this right
cool so what's next um
what if we want to do a 404 page right
we have this error page but for example
if we just copy this
forever page we put here error
and we also import the error page
by doing something like this
sorry if i went up a little bit too fast
but
i'm sure you you already used to make
paths and routes
so oh wait the page is not error
the page is called 404 here
and probably i'm gonna call it
page 404
so the thing about this is that i just
made a route
uh for slash 404
and if i go to that page like this
i will get the photo for but if i write
something else
i don't get anything basically the
router
will say like hey this is a pad but i
don't have any
component to render right so it will
just render the page navigation and the
footer
and the router view is just empty uh so
for that we just need to
use something like this which is a
wildcard
and well we put this at the bottom
uh because if you put it on the top
basically we
will do that everything goes to the
forum for page does is that
it will go uh route by route and if it
doesn't match any of this
well it will fall into this route and we
will have the 404
page right i put the code here
just so that you see that it's just the
path with an asterisk
so that's it
and well that's for our pages
now i want to show you uh a super pro
tip
optimization in optimization so let's
build this
this project you can use your terminal
or the one in bs code
to build the project
and what i want you to show you is how
this looks
and when it's built right because we we
have like a bunch of files here we have
uh component files we have router
file and the main.js and all of that but
when you build it you will basically
basically
convert all of that into js and css
files right
uh so after this is done um
you will see uh the
that everything is just one js file okay
here we have
well not one js file is two js files
with their
mappings uh but basically this is the
dependencies
and the app the well the app one is
the whole app like our components and
everything else right
uh so the interesting thing here is that
if we see this in
in our browser uh
for some reason my pc is a bit slow but
i wanted to show you
uh what are what's the size of of this
file oh well anyways it shows here
so you can see we have a
[Music]
12.6 kilobytes file right
in our app but the thing is that
we have a bunch of routes right like
uh we have four routes and probably the
the users are just gonna be seeing the
home page at the beginning and
they're loading everything right so
there's a trick for that
i'm gonna paste this code because this
is uh
a little bit long i'm gonna put it in
the chat don't worry
but basically if you just put this
instead of the regular thing with it
it will tell webpack to split
this into another file so that you can
load it separately
and basically the when when the
user first loads the page it will load
the home one
and well the app went and and then
the other ones will be in different
files for the page to load separately
and not
load like everything at the same time
and well this uh
this part here puts uh it is seems like
a comment but in reality
it's telling webpack to uh oh sorry you
got an error
oh yeah since i am i'm dynamically
importing checkout we don't need this
import we we are dynamically
importing it here so that's why it
failed
but yeah i was mentioning this part
seems like a comment but actually tells
webpack to
name the the file as checkout so that we
can identify them
easier but you can also just remove this
and webpack will
call it like a hash name or something
okay i'm gonna read uh questions while
well if there's no i'm saying that uh
charlie and jonathan are
taking care of that so that's cool okay
so now we go to the list
we have you you'll see that we have this
check out gis
and you can see that the app was reduced
by some kilobytes
and well some of them were added to the
checkout one it seems that it duplicated
in size
but probably because the uh well
there's some basis code that you need to
have but it's
it's still pretty small right like if
you have more components this will be
larger and that's when this pays off
right
when you can start taking out things
from from the main file
all right so
now that uh we're basically done with
routing we probably are going to be do
doing more routes but just
for for recap and before going to the
next part remember that
routes need a path a name and a
component
uh you can use the router view to to
load the corresponding component into
the page
and when you import them like this
you'll be benefiting from code splitting
also you can use the router link to um
to go to to the pages for navigation
instead of the anchor
tags and use the wildcard to catch all
of the roads and make them 404.
all right next topic fetching data
uh probably you you saw the
at the bottom of the homepage that we
have this
if we go to the view dev tools and
and see that the this component this
whole component is the client's
testimonials we have a loading animation
here
and we have the a testimonial also
so you
you we don't have any data right and we
need to
show some some data here so let's go to
this component the client's
testimonial so that i can show you uh
how
it is looking right now
here it is i'm gonna close the rest of
the tabs and
uh well luckily we we have here
an endpoint that will give us some some
json data
we can see it here and you can see we
have
an array with seven uh clients and
their pictures and also a description
right so we we're going to be showing
those
inside this well
inside this component the single
testimonial all right so the first thing
to do is to
uh well when should we fetch the data
right and i'm gonna
throw these questions to to the chat
when do you think we should chat
we should fetch the data of this
component
that one
okay well um meanwhile i'll just i just
saw that there's a question can you show
the component error in
index for router uh
yeah i can do that
sorry router yeah my pc is dying
so the the component is the page 404
this one is not
uh error because i don't i don't know i
don't know
why didn't i call it like that but it's
for for some reason
okay yeah i'm seeing answers right now
so yeah
some people are saying when the company
is created some people are saying when
it is mounted so yeah
probably both are not wrong
but i do prefer to do it after it is
mounted
when it is created sometimes you don't
have access to
parts of the browser so it's a better
practice in general to
to just do it in in the mounted hook
so let me show you how how does that
look
sorry for some reason
what yeah i i was trying to
type something in the chat but for some
reason it's getting me back to the
uh to the editor anyways mounted
yeah this is the mounted hook uh this
executes whenever
uh the component is already mounted and
the cool thing about this is that uh
well we can use axis here
and if you're used to a sync and a
weight we can use that syntax here
basically say like a sync and then a
weight
axios oh first we need to import axios
and then tell it to get the url we have
here
and we will set that up into a
response variable right
so now we have that response where
should we set that up
probably need some internal data
to do that right so we can put a data
here that returns
our clients
and
the clients by default will be just an
array empty like in case
uh the this fails it will still be an
empty array and oh a good question by
default mounted is already asynchronous
uh no you if you don't put this it's not
a synchronous and actually
when i do this mounted i'm not telling
it
uh to mount after the
this response is done actually the the
component will mount
and it will render and after that it
will
run this method right and we're gonna
see that because we
want the loader to show first and then
the
the response so now that we have the
response we
can just tell that our clients
is equal to the response
dot data
and well let's see if that worked and
well before going to the browser i'm
gonna let you write that down
and if that work we can click this claim
testimonial
and we'll see that we have our clients
array
full with the seven people from from the
json right that's cool
so well another good practice is what if
this fails
right we uh probably whipping this url
the
user doesn't have internet or something
and it will
fail so we can basically do a catch
and take the error
and a good practice is always lock the
error so that you can check
on your server what was there so i'm
just gonna do that
and also uh to know that this
uh is well that that
this is still uh returning something to
the response right so
we will just return an object with data
that is empty so that this doesn't break
anything if if we set response to no
uh we might have problems right so we
we better have the response with the
data as empty so that clients are
still empty and we don't get any errors
after that well we we are
fetching this but we're not showing
anything yet right so
let's fill that data inside our client
testimonial
as you can see we have name picture
description which is the same thing as
as in our clients method so we just use
a d4
here
sorry so before client
in clients as a key
is a good practice to use the the id of
the client
or whatever you're using that has that
is unique
it's not a good practice to use uh index
but some people do it
and but if you have an
index that's i mean uh a unique id
that's even better
and for name well we will put the claim
that name
picture the same
and description will be the same
oh yeah the url is in the code you can
look for
it inside your file
okay so i i'm just doing a v4 here and
everything inside this client
all is taking from all the clients each
one and the properties are set up
into this single testimonial file
and if that work we should see
a lot of our client testimonials here
there they are there are seven so
they're showing that's cool
but we still have our loader in the top
right
is not going away so
what can we do as i mentioned the
the mounted method will run after the
the
the component is mounted so this will
render even before fetching data
uh so we want to make the loading
animation disappear after
it has been loading right so we will
create a new loading data here
that is by default true
and in our mounted method
after we set their response data
we will say this dot loading
false i'm sorry equals false
right so we're telling it that uh our
loading
well we finished loading and it should
stop showing the loader
so here we just need to do an ape
to stop rendering it i mean to render it
only when it is loading right
so if it is not loading it will
disappear
cool so hopefully you you got to this
part
and now if you go to your site and
refresh
it you'll briefly see the loader and
then
the testimonials right so that's working
and the final thing we're i'm gonna
provoke an error here i'm gonna just put
like a fake
url to see what happens right
so it doesn't seem bad right like
uh yeah we see the loader then it
disappears
but the thing is that our component says
client testimonials
we don't have any so probably if we have
an error
we don't want to show anything right so
what i'm going to do
is that i'm going to create another data
property that is called error
select to false
and before returning here in the catch
i'm gonna say error
equals true sorry this dot
error equals true
and similar uh to the way we do it we
did it with the loading
we're gonna hide all of this with a b if
error
and i'm gonna get back to
to this part so you can see it
all right so
up story should be the opposite
if we don't have errors we show that the
component
so be if not error right
so that's it it is loading
it gets error so it just removes the
component probably
you can do something else like faking
some
testimonials or something but yeah
just uh just wanted to show you this
like this is a good practice to handle
errors when fetching data right
all right so now uh let me remove the
the error from the url so that we
get get back to getting our testimonials
um
for some reason we're getting like a
bunch of testimonials and we just want
to print
the first four right so what what will
you do
like the api gives us seven but we just
won the first four
any suggestions
splice array okay so
yeah that's an option you you can splice
it here before setting
into the the client's uh data
but uh well that's actually a good
option
in view one what i like to do is
something different like
uh well actually first i'm going to show
you like the bad practice right
some people like to do this after the
before
they just say
and well they also don't follow me on
this by the way
they just put an index here so if the
index is less than
four they they will render that
right but actually some of the linting
rules we have will prevent us from doing
this
if we try to go here it says hey
you should not use b4 within and with
any beef
right that's like a bad practice why
because you're
forcing whenever this gets re rendered
you first need to check for for this
evaluation and it's pretty simple right
you you're just checking
uh if it less if it is less than four
but i've seen some people even put
methods here so it can get really
uh complicated for for
and also if you have a lot of components
it will
make the site slow right so
if you don't want to do this and
well the splice option is is a good one
but i'm going to put a third option
which is have a computed property
and well if you know if you don't know
about uh computer properties
uh basically they're just like uh
variables that depend on on your data
right so for example we can call this
first for clients
and we will return
clients but
filtered by
uh the the same
evaluation we did in the before right so
we have
a client and
an id and
we just want the the ids that are less
than four
i'm sorry this this is not id this is
index
so why is this better than db in in
we did before uh basically because
we whenever we set this clients array
this will automatically evaluate and
rend and
render the the component on top right
when we were doing the beef we'll try to
do this evaluation for for each time it
renders
this way it will just render again if
clients change
oh good question computed will be called
first
or mounted actually computed is called
first
so for example the well
computed is called whenever something in
the data changes
so at the beginning clients is empty so
it will be called but
since it is empty the filter will also
return empty
then the mount that will execute will
change the clients
and this will execute again right so
this is basically like another data
you can treat it like that like just
another property in your data that will
change as you change the other
properties
so now if we did that correctly
oh it seems that it's not working but
let's check
if we go to the utep tools and check the
client testimonials
we can see that we have our seven
clients and this is the cool thing about
using computers
uh basically you can check that we have
the four clients so this is working fine
what is not working fine is that we're
not using this in the template right
so we need to go to the v4 and instead
of clients
we're going to be using the first four
clients
and that will render just those planes
okay so uh
hopefully you got this right because
now you're gonna do it by yourself we
have the same thing
in our products page if you go to
products
you can see we have the basically the
same thing we have
a url here we have a product widget
that is hardcoded with one value and
when you load this it you will get an
array of
products that we need to render with
this in this product widget
and also you have a loading animation so
it's basically the same we you can go to
uh
here to products and this is the page so
we need to render
a bunch of these products i'm gonna give
you probably 10 minutes
also for people that are probably would
like to take a break
uh get some water but well at 5 15
um i'm gonna check if you are done with
this part of exercise
and continue
also i'll be answering questions so
if you're not following the exercise
feel free to to start asking questions
for people that want an extra challenge
uh
you'll notice that there is a property
here called right side picture
uh that basically if you put it to true
the picture will be on the right if it
is false it will be on the left
so if you finish with that
try doing that every pearl shows in a
different side like
the first one on the left the second one
on the right the third one on the left
and so on
okay i'm seeing some answers to do the
the
right side thing
and yeah that uh
getting the module of of the product id
well probably i wouldn't take the
product id in this case is
uh the product ids are one two three
four five but
probably the uh when you are working
with a real database the ids won't be
that way right you can't have like one
five seven
or something like that
if okay yeah if you meant the index
that's another option but
that will be similar to having a
well now that that's actually fine and
i'm just gonna show
you um another way we can do it also
with computer properties
but we're gonna give other trimmings for
people to
um to finish
or you can put yes if you are already
done
to see how many of you want to continue
i mean well in the chat it's okay but
it's better in the
buttons you have so that i can count
them
by the way if you handle the error
that's fine i just
didn't do it because i'm lazy and
well i already did it in the last part
but well you can copy paste the
the way we catch the error
so just to show you another way to do
that right
side thing for the people that are
already salted with the
index module modulo 2
you can also call a method here that
it's called probably
something like this art because we want
the odds on one side
and we send the index
and we can have this method here
this is just another way of doing it if
you are ready to do it with
the way it shows in in the chat that's
fine
so yeah that's another way right like
calling a method
and that's the same as put it in line
but i have another way to do this and
well we're on time so if you
solved it that's cool if not we're going
to continue
uh instead of calling a method inside a
v4 we can also do a computed property
and why is this good well because the
same reason
of the client's testimonials example
basically we're evaluating here for
every product this method so whenever
something changes
everything will re-evaluate and this is
not that bad like calling a method is
not that bad
uh the the downside of this is that
uh if you go to to this project
product uh component you'll see here the
product looks
but you don't know why they're rendering
one
side on the other until you click one of
them and you see like oh okay this
this has the right side picture set to
one
and this one to zero right so
uh i need a better way to do a computed
property
and i show you how we also do a computer
here
and we're to call these products
with alignment
and we're going to return
this.products.map
we're going to iterate over each product
and also get the index
and for each product we're gonna return
this is es5 with the structuring
we're gonna return the same product but
with an extra property that is called
alignment sorry
and well this can be the method we
created
on the bottom
okay some oh okay
i'm just gonna put it in a method i'm in
a
constant here just because it's easier
to read
and actually i i want to change the
e-stop to
put true or false so i'm just going to
check if this is zero
and yeah this seems
a little convoluted if you're not used
to functional programming but you can do
this also with a
regular four but what we are doing is
that
we uh we check for each product and
their indexes
what will be the alignment and we create
a completed property
basically well a new product with this
new
alignment property so that will be set
here
and we can use this instead of the
regular products
and here we can just say product
dot alignment and we can get rid of the
index here
so the advantage of this is just that
uh we don't have any logic in our
template right
but also uh well if you use the method
in the template that's also like
not having a lot of logic because you're
just calling a method
but the real advantage is that if you go
to your page
and for some reason it is not showing
okay you can see the products page
and you can see that you have your
regular products and then you have
the products with alignment and you can
see here that
they have their alignment set to true or
false
depending if they're odd or not
also a question do we always have to
define a functioning methods if we want
to use it in computed
no actually that's a really good
question
we can basically if
the method is not using anything from
the state or
the properties of the object you can
extract it like
constant is odd
equals this function right and you can
make it probably another function
and remove it from from methods
and instead of using this dot you just
use
the function you declare here
uh oh and yeah this can be well
the linter is telling me that i can just
return this
and yeah i need to define it on top
i just wanted to keep it on on the
bottom so that you could see that i just
extracted the same function but yeah you
can do this if your method doesn't need
to know anything about
the component you can definitely do this
yeah like you mentioned uh yeah we just
use it if we want to access the state
or perhaps cool
so now that we are done with our
products
uh what about
well going to the actual product right
we are not uh
for some reason it got us to the home
page and if we
remember the router thing uh
probably that's because we don't have a
router link so let's get back to
um to our project and we can go to the
product widget which is uh the one we're
using there and let's check for uh
the show details button which is this
one
and we have an anchor so we need just to
change that
to router to
and then go to prolog id right
the cool thing is that we have already
this product editing
but uh let's see if you're still awake
what what will we need to
to make this work
again you're not awake
[Laughter]
don't worry well to make it work because
if we right now
just click it
well for some reason it's not working
oh sorry it's router link and
i don't know why just put router there
okay so we have a 404
so that's because we don't have the
route
and this is another like i could get
back i mean this i could
explain this in in the router section
but uh we don't we didn't have a way to
do it so
uh now we have a good example when we
have
products here and we can be like many
products and
it's not just one route right and uh
i don't think it should you should be
like declaring one route
per product like product number one
product number two
and so on so the way you do that in
here in the router is that you take this
single product
here that we have here
and we're gonna do some string
interpolation just to concatenate some
text basically we're gonna say like
okay when single product has slash
and then something that something will
be our id
right and we're gonna call this product
and we need to put here the single
product
okay oh lovely sorry
and well getting back to this so you can
see it
uh how does this work um basically
when we put this semicolon we're telling
the view router that this could have
like anything
and that anything should be set into
this
id this could be any any name you want i
put id because it's
the mo the thing that made more sense
but you can probably use product or
something like that
but yeah id makes more sense because
that's the thing we're using here
and if we go to to our pdf tools
check the route you'll see that we have
the full pad
product one it it use the
product route and when we collapse these
params here we have the id right so
that's cool because we want to use that
uh but well before going
uh before using that that param uh
we need to do something else uh here we
have the
the product and you can see we have just
a printer
and but actually this could be like any
other
of the other products right like if we
get back to the
products page we click here in a toner
we should see that toner right
right now we don't have an endpoint to
get a single product so we should use
the same
uh the the same data we already have
so i will tell you okay let's
inside the this single product page
probably we can fetch
the data of all the products and just
look for
for the one that we have in their url
and
and set it here right but the thing is
that
we don't want to do that because we
already are fetching the data before
and sorry
and we want just to reduce this data
right
so to do that we need to to go to the
next step which is
using vx but well
before getting into vx i'm just going to
give you a quick recap of what we did
we use a sync await for prominences to
set our lowering state
we also used try catch well
catch in in the promise for fetching
data and use
and set errors also uh we don't use
beefs inside before because that's about
practice
and instead we use the computed props to
make uh to change the presentation of
the data
and the props and a path with
semicolon and the variable name we'll
put the variable inside
this route params object
um okay so if all of this is clear
now we can go to to the next part which
is view x
anyone in the chat knows what vx is
or how many of you have have you used vx
you can
click no or yes in in the buttons of
of the zoom
okay thread management for view yeah
manages to state the
app well the state of the app not
necessarily
because well every component has a state
and actually the main state
is in our main.js file so
we're not setting a state here but we
could right and every component is like
a
uh another part of of the main state
so ux is um is not the state of the app
it is more like a tool
to handle the state management
uh between uh uh between components
and yeah well the main usage we're going
to be doing is
for example here we we have this page we
go to a single page
there's some data that should be passed
but it's difficult because these
two companies don't know each other and
also
you can see we have a checkout button
here with a number
and if we add the cart to the cart uh
the product
this should change right and also these
two components don't know each other
that's
when we use view when we want to
communicate components that are
really far away if they were just like a
parent and a child or something like
that that would be easier but
in this case they're separate components
and well let me get back to the
presentation just to show you something
really quick
uh we've been using view components
right now and they have their own
uh data properties and all computed and
methods so imagine that bx is like a
big b component well not not big
component but a big
state or global state that we have for
for all of the components where
they will communicate in this way they
will dispatch
an action then this section will be able
to
get any data from that component and
also from
any api or wherever you want to connect
with
after that the data will will be
committed to change the state with the
mutation
and we in the devtools we can see those
mutations we're going to see
later how that works and that mutation
will change
the state the state will
will basically be updated and tell
all of the view components that have a
reference to that part of the state to
render again with that new value
so if if you have this view this seems
like basically like
data right like when when you change
data
uh it will render the component so this
is similar this is like a
a share data outside of your component
but that you can reference in your
component
and well oh that's a good joke you can
give yourself and communicate your
children with your grandparents
yeah this will be the cellphone
basically
um cool so how do we start adding
bx well
we will start similar to the router
we have this index file which is
basically a view of ux
empty store and here
in our main.js we're gonna import it
just like this
and the same as the view router just put
the store in there
and this is a cool thing about the view
ecosystem
since all of the tools are custom made
for view they're
super simple to to install and set up
right
probably if you've used react or jquery
or
other things that have like a lot of uh
third-party
tools they're sometimes more difficult
to set up
than this
so now that we have that well first
let's see if uh
if that works i'm gonna get back to this
so that you can see import store
put the store right here and in my
well we don't have anything in the state
so
we want to have the products right so
if we get back to to the store index i'm
just gonna
do like if this was data so i'm gonna
set
up my products as an empty array up
sorry products
with s
and if this works then we should be able
to see well
it will refresh because it says like hey
there's new state or something so i'll
need to refresh
and if everything is set up you can
click here in the load state
button and you will see that we have
products
and they're empty because we set it up
like that so that means your bx is
working
i'm gonna wait a little bit until you
get here like uh if
some someone has a problem please put in
the chat
but if you're here then click yes
so that i can continue
i'll do it okay cool yeah it seems like
the
majority has it working yeah it's pretty
simple
hopefully that that's good you you don't
you didn't get lost
so yeah we have our products here um
similar to what
we did in our component
uh we need to when whenever we we go to
this page we
we need to fetch the products also in in
the single
product page we need to do it here so we
will do like a mounted
and fetch the data then update the data
and render it right uh in this case i'm
just gonna
take the products page because that's
already done
and take these uh
basically this part of the
of fetching data and put it inside an
action
so we are going to call the action fetch
products
and also this needs to be in the sync
function because it's going to
fetch that data and
well the difference here is that we we
saw in the diagram
we should not be setting the products
directly right so i'm going to comment
this oh and i need to import axis
and well we have the response but what
we want to do
to set up the products is to uh
commit my changes into annotation so how
do we do that we
we receive here a context object
that will help us to commit the changes
and well probably we can call this we
we need an identifier so this is going
to be set products
and we're going to send the response
that data
the important thing here is that your
mutation should have the same name
that we put here so i'm gonna copy that
i'm gonna call my mutation set products
and we we saw in the diagram that the
mutations
will set the the state right they are
the ones that change
the state so that's why uh
they also receive the state that's a
cool thing and they will receive the
the products we sent in the com in the
commit
function as a second parameter so here
we can say
state.products equals products
and we can now get rid of this
pretty simple right basically just we
just
uh the two lines that we put here we
just have to expand it a little bit
and you may say why not just setting
sending a
a commit from my component that's
because
you might need to do more things in your
actions it's a good practice to just
separate
actions from mutations and not let your
components just mutate freely
the uh the state
so now if we have this we just need to
connect it to the component and how do
we do that
well uh
since we we we already are doing this in
in the action we just remove this
also we can remove axes and
we need to somehow get that action right
so for that we will
import an utility from axios that is
called
i mean from ux that is called map
actions
and what this does is that it will help
us to
make an action a method in the component
so we can create again our methods here
and the way we use the map actions is by
using
three dots to the structure and map
actions and it's an object well inside
parenthesis and then an object we
call the method we i mean the
the the way we're going to call the
action inside our component
oh sorry it was fetch products
and the way it was called in vx which is
also fetch products
you can name them differently in case
you probably
if you already had like a method that is
called this way you can change the name
so
that names on the store don't collide
with your
own method names right and
here in the mounted we had the await
and the difference is that we're we are
not going to do the
access call we're just going to fetch
products
and you can see i'm not assigning
anything to
to to this right because well if we get
to to our actions there uh we're not
returning anything here we're just
changing the state
and that's a good practice we should not
return anything we just
should mutate the state so that the
component can
grab that part of the state and actually
that those products are not going to be
longer uh internal state they're going
to be global states so we can get rid of
this
and in our computer we're going to use
another utility we have map actions to
get the actions
well we also have map state to get the
state so
we're going to import that
and inside our computer properties we
can use it similarly
and well the name of of the
of the property of the state is products
well we're going to call it products but
also it's called products
in the state right but this similar to
actions we can call it whatever we want
and if all of these work i'm gonna wait
a little bit more
for you to to to get this
but if all of that work we should not
see any change right we just moved the
fetch functionality to the store
and also the state to the store and we
don't have it
we don't no longer have it in data
oh and the cool thing is that since this
is called the same products
in our template we didn't change we
didn't need to change anything
and also here in in our computer
property we we can just call it the same
so let's get back to our parallel box
page
there we have it
and we can see we have our products here
and if if we inspect the component
we can see that we no longer have uh
data with with the products but we have
these viewex bindings
it's telling us that products come from
ux and
it's basically the same data right
cool so now it's exercise time again
we we just did this for the products
page but now you're gonna do it for
the single product page
basically add the the actions and
and state to fill this product
and for now you can do it with the first
product that
is in the store because this is just a
single product we don't need a b4 here
and after that or i mean if you have
time we
can as an extra challenge you can set
the product from the id of the router
but if you just get the first product
with uh with map state and map actions
uh that should be fine and we're gonna
see how to do the rest
so you have 10 more minutes for this at
5 51.
i'll check back to see if you could set
the single product
page with with the state
okay and i'm just gonna start doing the
same
with this for a single product just in
silence in case you're
you're following a log
yeah right also if you're way behind
don't worry we are gonna be uh
before the the next chapter we we you
can just get check out
to to a branch and
and follow us along so you can
see if you type git branch you can see
we have all of these branches
i totally forgot about this but we
started in router
uh you can well when we fetch data we
started here
when we we're working with
uh with bx started here and
after finishing this view expire we're
gonna move to the
form validation part all right
so how are you doing we have three more
minutes well four
is anyone done remember
just render the first component
if you have time
just also take the well try to take the
one from the router
yes i can show index.js in the store
all right so
oh nice victor already kind of got
uh how to to get that well
that's that works um using this product
and then
just the the id of the params because
the id is the same as the index of of
the array
right but if we were using uh
strings or something as an id that that
wouldn't work but yeah that's a way to
do it
in in this case and
actually i'm just going to show you uh
real quick but
what i've done to see if you do if you
did something similar
we'll basically just import it uh
the the map actions and the map state
uh also oh sorry it's in the single
product
yeah well the same imported map actions
map state
for data i just made another loading
data to
set it to false after it finishes the
promising the promise of
fetching products and also
mapped the actions to use use the fetch
products here
map the state to use the products and my
product is just the first one uh so i
got it put it like this
and then in in the template you just put
a
beef loading oh by the way if you want
you can
also link this
to the products page like this
and set this to loading just to show the
the loading animation
and set the product data right
pretty simple pretty straightforward so
now uh
a way to to do the the the product
well the single product by uh by url
is first convert these
products array into a dictionary and
i'm just gonna copy paste this uh
because we're running a little bit short
on time
uh but yeah we can call these
the products dictionary oh sorry
and basically we're just going to be
transforming
uh the products data like this
i'm going to paste it in the chat so
that you can also
use it uh but basically we're just
iterating over each product and just
setting it up with their id
as an as a key in in
in the object right so now we can use
uh what what some of you mentioned here
which is this route
this is the way we we uh
get reference to to the route object in
in
in the view instance and the params
then id right
so we're going to see how this works
i clicked a toner which is the id3
and if we get to the single product
component with the video tools you can
see that
sorry then okay my products dictionaries
here
so you can see i have one two three four
is like this
and for some reason it's getting me the
fourth one
i'm gonna check why but anyways uh it's
taking
route params id which is three
and yeah
i'm not sure where it is getting giving
me the fourth one instead of the third
one
probably that's because this is a a
string
or anyone knows why
or let me just check if it was just
some kind of error oh yeah it was some
kind of error
for some reason it didn't refresh
correctly and it
gave me the wrong uh product but yeah
oh wait oh
okay for the one it's giving me the
black toner for some reason this this is
uh
why we need the desktops right to see
why this is happening so the id is 2
which is this one
id2 should be this one but the route
has the param id one but you can see
this is a string this is not a number so
i believe that's the problem for some
reason
right
oh wait no i i just realized i'm not
using the product dictionary
sorry my bad
yeah now we're getting the right one
there we go cool so
this is the the view expert and
we're gonna need to fast forward to a
branch because there uh
we need to go to the formalization
there's a lot of things
that you you're gonna be seeing that we
change uh in the store
after this but uh basically if you want
to follow along well first
let's recap uh when the state needs to
be
shared we use vx basically when we need
to share them between these
uh try to keep the store simple also i
didn't mention this but
as you saw i didn't get the loading into
the state
because that would be like a global
loading and we don't want that we just
use the loading whenever a component
uses it right
and keep it local uh just the things
that you need to share
put those in in the store use map
options back map state we didn't get to
see map getters but it's really
really similar getters are like computed
properties but for the store
and uh well actions should not return
anything and actions can be promises and
also can call other actions now to jump
to the form validation
if you want to keep your changes uh
probably you can
get stash or something uh
but if not you can just hit reset
hard like i'm doing here let me just put
this bigger
that will remove all of your changes but
uh anyways you we don't need it because
we will go to the
uh form validation one sorry that
that gco is git check out
i have some abbreviations but kit
checkout form validation
that's what you you need to do right
so if you're here well i'm gonna give
you
some seconds to change the branch
okay if yeah thank you jonathan that's
that's the command so now
we we can see what happened here because
a lot of things are the same but for
products we can now add
card uh we we in the store we have
more actions basically to to create uh
that link between the the
the card and the checkout button and and
this other card if you
see i'm gonna add three yellow toners
we have ten so now we have 13 and here
we are
we have our yellow thunders you can
check the code for this uh
later but well now we are here we want
to check out
and well the form is asking me luckily
it's not asking you right now for
uh credit cards we we don't have time to
do a full
uh store but we're gonna check at
these that tell us putting their email
on their phone so that we can call them
and tell them how to pay us right so uh
the thing right now is we click buy and
it just refreshes the page and
we're not getting any data right so
let's check how that component looks
like and if we go to
to this checkout component
you'll see we already have these uh form
inputs these are custom components i
made
which basically just have an input
and whenever you change something they
will emit
this input uh event
and they receive a lot of parameters
that will render uh
even if they have an error for example
so this is a
pretty useful component whenever you're
you you're
using forms to have just one component
for the whole thing like validation
showing errors
and well basically uh don't mess with
that
with that on on your page but in the
component itself right
so yeah we need to fill this in with
with our own
data so let's do that first
we're going to create a data object well
data method with
that returns we need to start the email
at the beginning will be empty and the
phone which will also
be empty right and
if we check that here
i'm sorry you need to refresh so that
the bit of tools
okay we have it them here
they're empty that's cool but we need to
for them to update when we change
something right and
have you used a b model before
like this b model
oops sorry this should begin so yeah you
can answer in the chat have you used
this before
okay yeah there are some people using it
that's cool
uh well
you you will probably notice that well
probably you have usb models
with inputs directly right and
we're using a custom component here so
why does this work
basically because our component
is emitting an input with the
value and also is receiving the value
and that value is
rendered uh
where is it oh i forgot but well
this should be value
equals value
yeah so we have two way data binding
whenever something
uh changes this value it will update it
here
and also when this changes this will
emit an input
and this is basically the manual way to
do a v model
so if you want any of your components to
have some functionality similar to v
model you can do it like that
just a quick tip um
yeah if if we check this here we can
start
writing we check our checkout page and
we can see that it is updating
right all right so
now we need to validate this uh the good
thing is that
i already put some validators here you
just need to
remove the comments but we already have
an email validator we can check it
if you want there in the validation
validators folder
it's a complex project basically based
from stack overflow
and that i know it works so don't worry
trying to understand it
and it will just return a string telling
you the error
or it will be empty if there are no
errors
right the same for the phone validator
uh if it is empty he will say that is
required
if it's something that is not numbers it
will
tell you this and if it's more or less
than 10
numbers it will tell you this if
everything
passes then it will return just an empty
string right
so where will would you think we should
do the validation
this is like an open question i i i'll
wait for you to answer on the chat
where do you think we should be
validating
this or where would you do it
a blur okay a watcher
uh i'm not a fan of watchers but yeah
that's
probably another option yeah it's not a
bad option
actually if you if you have used
watchers
um yeah that's that's a good
and submit that's another one what about
if we do it on submit i mean if we just
do it in a watcher
uh whenever we type we will get the
errors right
and if we do it on submit um
that's cool because we we see the errors
when we submit
and not when we are typing but after
submitting it will still show the error
and we need to submit again to know if
there were
uh works i mean we got rid of the error
so we will do a combination of uh on
submit and the watcher but instead of a
watcher
we're going to use computed properties
probably you'll notice that
i'm fan of computed properties because
they're super cool and
i will say that 90 of the times you
you'll be better using computed
properties than a watcher
and you'll you'll see the way this can
get solved
with the computed uh okay so
first let's do a computed
property oops
well two two properties in in computed
that
will tell us if the phone had has
servers
sorry phone
this will store the phone number
and this other one will start the email
error
and we're just going to be returning
the phone validator
executing with the phone
and the same for the email
and this could be in a watcher
and yeah probably you can just watch for
the phone and check the the
uh well if it has servers or or not
and probably set another data but
the cool thing is that if you do it this
way basically whenever you change the
phone or what or
other thing you you also change this one
errors
but if you need to know if the whole uh
form is valid uh uh you
you will also need to to do that in
either of these two right but with
computer properties we
we can just say form is valid
and the form will be valid if
these phone errors
is empty and also the
email error
is empty right and this is why i prefer
computed properties over
uh the watcher because you just need to
to
basically check over these other
computer properties and you
automatically
get if the form is valid
and well uh
when we when we submit i mean sorry
now that we have this we can bind these
errors to the ones that we have
on our inputs right so we have this
error field
this is the phone so we put the phone
error here
and the email error here
and here's the problem right like it is
already
well that's cool but we don't really
want to validate until we submit right
so i'm gonna do this a little bit quick
because we are running out of time and
we i want to give some space
for for the testing part so
um hopefully you catch up if not time
you can review the video so
for uh getting when when the form is
submitted we just
have to listen to a submit event
and use this permanent
prevent is useful whenever you
want to avoid the refreshing of the page
and instead of
inside the function doing an
event.default.prevent default
like we did on jquery or other
frameworks we can just do it with this
shorthand in view
so we're gonna call a submit method
that we haven't created but we're gonna
create it here
submit
and we we want to uh
to validate things only when it has
already been submitted right
so we we're going to create a
validate flash
at the beginning will be false but here
we will set it to true
and oh i already have
met that's right okay
and when this is true then i mean when
this is false if we should not
validate
so if we don't need to validate we just
return
the empty like if there were no errors
we do the same for the email
and well here in oh i already have the
submit order
okay uh never mind i i'm not gonna use
this one
but i'm gonna copy the comments from
this
so like in the comments says if the form
is valid
uh we check it with this that
form is valid
then we should send the order right
and we're going to see the console.log
only when it is valid
let's see if that worked so i'm writing
no errors no errors that's cool click
buy
i get errors and i didn't get the
the console log so i'm gonna
put a fake email here
and fake number i'm gonna click
buy and we get the order console log
all right so well that's for form
validation
uh any questions so far because you were
pretty quiet the whole
part
uh well for recap you can make your own
custom
be modeled when needed to simplify
things
also use at submit.prevent to avoid
refreshing the page
you can validate in real time with
computed props
and also you can
oh i didn't check this
but yeah we can do that super quick
and i'm gonna just send you to the
homepage
so if we we use router polish
this that router
push and the home page
whenever we submit the form well
actually it should take us to the tanks
form let me check if we have the the
route
oh yeah we have it cool so i'm just
going to send it to
to the tanks page
and we can get back we can feel
this
and there we have the thank you baby
so you can programmatically also
navigate
with the router right cool
well now the last part and not because
it's the least important but
test should be important always i
actually
uh it's a good practice also to create
first test and then make them pass but
in this case we're going to do the
opposite so
you can follow along if you also check
out
in the branch for testing
which is called tests did check out
tests
but i believe our checkout table is
already
there yeah we have the checkout table
so let's see what's what we're going to
test see we have
uh this table and you just saw that we
have the items the quantity and the
price right
and then we have a grand total
uh where we show the the total of the
of the all the items multiplied by by
the
their price right so we want to test the
total is correct so we're going to go to
uh to the test folders we already have
this checkout table
dot spec dot js this is the way that
uh yes identifies that this is a test
if it ends with dot spec or dot test.js
it will run the test
so um well i'm i'm going to show you
real quick what's this file and what we
have so we have
beta studios we're importing the shallow
mount function
this function helps us to mount
the component without its childs like if
we just want to
test that component you can use shallow
mount and it will
do the test super quick we're importing
the table that we want to test and here
we we have some
dummy data uh similar to to the products
we
we store uh in the cart so that we can
touch the
component so
now this is yes when uh this
function described is is yes uh
we we did we can specify like what are
we doing
here so we're describing that we are
testing the checkout table
and then we we put an anonymous function
to do the tests we can nest these
describes this is not a guest class and
i'm not a yes expert but
if you you can probably check out and
just documentation so that you can see
how this works
and on the it we we will put our tests
so i i put already this uh two each
because we want to check that the
checkout table
it renders the grand total correctly and
also it emits
the remove item from cart event when the
delete button is clicked
so first to to check if the grand total
is correct we're gonna uh we're gonna
do a wrapper
where we're gonna store our component
when it is mounted
so we will we're going to call shallow
mount
then the component we want to mount
and then in an object we will put the
properties
and this is called props data i think
no time this is gonna error
but well we're gonna put the items in in
the car by id
inside this props data
basically this props data is whatever is
going to be sent to the component if we
check this item
by item in cart by id and we look at the
sorry the checkout table which is the
one we're testing
let me close the rest we have these
items incurred
by by id right so we're just sending
that over with these
items let's check our data we have
uh one item here with well
four first items and each one
costs a hundred and this second item
we have one because 50. so
if i did my math correctly this should
be
450 dollars right
so the way we test that is that we
expect
something to be something right so for
for starters i'm going to just put
expect 2 to be true
just to see if everything is working
correctly
and we can
run this
uh with npm run you need sorry
test colon unit
and you can see it's running the
checkout table
test and it passed well the
it passed the two past the first one
because i just expect 3 to be true
and the second one because i didn't
expect anything right
so let's start doing something uh
let's check first where our total is so
our total is in this
table and a good practice is to
add an identifier like data test
for uh getting this data from the test
um i i don't like using classes or ids
because
if the class changes because of css
changes the
test will break right so we use this
data test
grand total and we can look for it in
the test like this
we just say wrapper
dot bind then put in
square brackets data current test total
data test grantoral sorry so this will
find that
that that html node so we could
call this total node
and basically we will expect that total
node
dot text to be
450. oh it's text so i'm gonna put it as
a
string this is a method like
that every wrapper or compo every html
note has inside butter studies so you
can call it like this
and now you run the test again
you'll see that something failed but the
cool thing is that
we're almost there it is printing also
the dollar sign and the
two zeros so we just need to add that to
the test and it should be fine right
okay so we do that
and by the way you can run this with
double dash then double dash again and
watch
and it will keep running
and whenever you do a change it will
tell you
it will run the test again so
you can see it passed that's cool i can
remove a zero save you you saw the
test run again and it should crash
well not crash but uh show that it has
an error
very cool
well let's do the same thing for buttons
super quick because we're
almost on time so we
just mount the the checkout table and
now we expect
we are going to take the wrapper
and we're going to look for the button
remember the delete button
luckily i already added that
data test delete button here
we can search for it with the find
and we can call this delete button
and we're gonna trigger a click so you
do that this way
and the thing that we're going to expect
here is not a change in the value
because it just
will uh
th this will oh sorry this is the lead
button
this should just emit a an event so
we expect the wrapper
it
is a function that will give you all of
the emitted events
sorry it's wt 1 m
then remove
item from cart which is
the name of the event and
we're going to check the length because
it should have
be called one time
right
so if we do that
this should pass oh it imported
something for some reason
and now i'll get to the components as
you can see i'm listening for the click
i call this remove item from cart and
it will just emit this remove item from
cart
and you can see it passed it was called
one time if i try to
say like hey call it two times
it will say no
there you go so it says like hey i i was
expecting to
but no it was just cold once so that's
fine
cool all right so
super quick repa recap on view tests
utils um you well i didn't show you this
but
you should decouple your components for
easier testing uh remember we had
the some components with the direct
directly calling actions and and state
i was doing the same for this checkout
table but
the problem is that i will need to mock
the state to make this work which could
be a little bit harder
so what i did is that i just did a
checkout table provider that will get
everything from the store
using map actions and and getters and
just call the same component with the
data
so that way we can just easily test
the the component without having to mock
all of the store
also shallow mount will not mount nested
components you can use it for
faster tests you can find nodes within
your components with data test
selectors like we did and like i
mentioned about using glasses and ids
because they can break your test if
someone changes it
for other reasons like styles or
something and
tests are more valuable if if you just
check functionality
if you saw i didn't check like oh this
should have like this css class
or this should be inside a a div inside
a
paragraph that has this class right
that's
that's not really scalable when you test
things
all right so before passing to the q and
a
section i just want to show you uh
this feedback survey
let me just copy the link so that you
can visit it
but it will make us super happy if you
can give us any feedback uh
for improving this course and and also
in this
survey you'll find that you can also
answer for other courses that you're
interested in so i'm just gonna
uh leave that for some seconds and
but we can start with q a um if you have
any questions
related or not to what we saw but
related to view
just should
yeah the video is going to be shared
actually if you go to
to youtube and look for whiteline
academy
uh you'll find that we already have a
bunch of videos on
many courses so yeah this will be
uploaded eventually and i think that
also they will send you a reminder in
the email for you to check
oh yeah anyway or to learn about uh view
uh well i i i actually put these
resources
where most of the good practices are
because this is the official
documentation of
everything we saw like the router the
the view test studios ux and also
the cookbook is super good because they
showed you
also real world cases and how they will
solve it so that's another good one and
view documentation is awesome
you'll see that you don't probably need
a book if you just read their
documentation
okay uh this uh
question that is really hard to answer
like which is better view
angular or react i think it depends on
your case
uh er everyone
any of those frameworks as their pros
and cons
uh for example uh well
react is the biggest one is backed by
facebook
and basically uh has a a pretty big
community so everything has already been
done for react right
and basically if you if you don't you
have a problem doing something
uh most probably someone already solved
it so that's the advantage of react
but the disadvantage is that it's hard
to to learn
and they're changing things a lot like
they just introduced
hooks some months ago and people are
people are
just getting to them and they are
learning to do uh the class well
on learning to do the class uh
components or
well having difficult time doing
components one way or another
angular it forces to have you typescript
i mean to use typescript so that's cool
if you're doing
an enterprise app actually in my project
i use
view with typescript but i think angular
3 or 2 i don't remember which version uh
forces it
so that's a pro of angular if you want
to see it
that way but also it's a con because you
uh if your team doesn't know typescript
that will be hard and view
has a smaller community than react
probably bigger than angular
but the advantage is that is the most uh
easy of the three to to learn in my case
and my team
i choose view because we were using
well my team had a lot of experience
using php and the
system we were doing was going to be a
mix of php and
and well front-end with javascript
so view was easier for them to learn
because they were already experts in php
but not in javascript
and then if i had chose react for
example
so that's why i mentioned it depends on
your personal case on your team
uh oh okay well
i i think uh i just skipped the the
question
how do you handle errors on the store
actions
that's a really good question probably i
i will say that since you don't return
anything
you just reject the promise remember you
it's a good practice to
re uh to make that promise then you just
reject the promise with an error and
that component that is using the action
can
handle the error if you need to change
the i mean to
share the error i will say probably
handle the error like if if you were
waiting for products to
to be filled in the array and the array
is empty and the problem is already
uh finished then you will put an error
like oh
and a product is found right because the
promise is finished but
the the mutation i mean there was no
mutation it didn't change
um the object i mean the array right so
you can put an
error on every component depending on on
what
change of state you you were waiting i
what i wouldn't suggest is to add a
an error state in your store
um and i don't suggest the error thing
because
you might have like error for a for
something error for
other thing and that can become a mess
okay so these links you have are just a
personal preference or have any impact
in view like performance avoid errors
uh okay so yeah that's a good question
and let me get back to
um to this
part where we have the configuration for
this link
uh the essential ones actually this
plug-in
view peter essential has like many rules
there you can look for eslint
view and the essential ones are
essential because they do affect
uh performance so i i will say or they
have
other problems that if if you
uh if you don't use you you you make
a narrowing with those essential rules
and you will have problems so oh yeah
here are the rules
there are some base rules that you
cannot disable then you have the
essential ones
and actually
let me see okay yeah these are for error
prevention
so yeah most basically all of these are
to prevent errors and also
performance issues then there's the
strongly
recommended which these are just like uh
styles
per like personal preferences like if
you want html self closing tags and or
stuff like that you you can enforce
those things
and the priority c is recommended and
it's just
minimizing arbitrary choices for
your team to not discuss like hey we
should not use
uh we we should have the for for example
ordering components is like
you should put first data then uh
computed then methods or
there's an order or of those things
right so
i will say use essentials and the other
ones if you
like them use them too or you can
basically activate or deactivate the
ones that you don't want
cool so i think those are all the
questions i believe
uh well thank you everyone and
uh i would like for you to virtually
clap for
the mentors and that were helping me and
answering
all of the questions to uh they're doing
a great job and and they're volunteers
so
i'm pretty grateful that they were
helping me on this
part of the course and oh okay another
question
what topics would you put in a vgs
advanced level course
okay uh probably i will put
some extra tools like nox js
but that that will be a course on itself
right
nox.js is a framework that basically
makes server side rendering with the
everything we we did in our site is
client-side server
right so if you turn off javascript it
won't work
but if you use noxios there's a lot of
things
that this framework does already out of
the box and help you to server side
render to
um handle big sites actually the the
site that i mentioned that has like uh
two billion
or i remember how many billion uh
requests per month
uh uses knoxville yes
and while other topics i'm not sure
probably go deeper into
vuex or other
well like for example we didn't see
animations there's
uh special components for animations in
view
there's like a lot of things that could
go in advanced course
all right well we're uh
we're on time so thank you everyone for
for joining and
as i mentioned the video will be on
youtube so that you can uh
rework all of these and well thank you
everyone for
forgetting this afternoon have a good
time
see ya
you